Jim Jordan who I happen to like a lot
congressman from Ohio who I think is
doing great work and fighting big Tech
and fighting for free speech and a whole
bunch more he went on Chuck Todd's
Sunday propaganda show Meet the Press it
he was a great show and I was growing up
about 30 years ago but it no longer is
very sad to say and here is Jim Jordan
going off on Chuck's hot now note the
way Chuck Todd is asking these questions
and you tell me is Chuck Todd an
impartial Observer is he is he a
journalist in his manner or is he a
Democrat activist take a look executed
president Trump had documents locked in
a room with Secret Service protecting
them President Biden had documents in
his garage and in a think tank that was
funded by the Chinese I think there's a
difference president Trump was the only
guy who was actually president you talk
about that you're worried about the
Chinese and and honey
they took pictures they took pictures of
are you don't worry about that no I'm
not but they took pictures of of the
documents at Trump's house they took no
pictures of Dr defect it's not just me
who would like to know what went on here
Senator Warner said it last week he
would like to get a briefing he went to
see the documents and guess what yeah
the guy's saying no but they took
pictures
in Trump's home the issue is not whether
Joe what Joe Biden did no the issue the
issue isn't under the law that's the
issue the issue of treatment you do not
seem to ever see the same conspiratorial
problems when it's a republican those
were all investigated for four years and
they continued
does Chuck Todd seem like an impartial
Observer there trying to get to the
truth or does he seem like a lawyer for
the Democrats no matter what Jim Jordan
says about the difference between what's
going on here between the the Biden
docks and the Trump docks Chuck Todd is
fighting him on that do you think that
is how he treated Adam Schiff for all
the years that Adam Schiff was peddling
January 6 nonsense in Russia collusion
you know the answer I don't even have to
explain it to you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]